for years the rains have failed and
rivers have dried up leaving people with
nothing to eat and little to drink in
southern Madagascar last year the world
food program warned that global warming
is creating a food crisis more than a
million people need Aid and many are
close to starving DW's Adrian Krish
visited the region of Amber vombe where
the drought is putting communities there
in a desperate situation
this is Mana Vuvu River or what's left
of it for two years residents of chiambe
have to dig in the riverbed their main
source of water
we are truly suffering my
now it's really dry dry no rainfall at
all
the rainy season should have already
started but once again people are still
waiting liferai and her family left
their Village and came to town because
of the drought back home everything had
run dry but here things were not much
better
but this is what we can afford to rent
our house is in the village far from
here but we come here because we need
access to water we brought all the kids
here and now they work as water carriers
fetching water and selling it is their
only option of earning money for food
every morning this is the reality for
tens of thousands in the region who live
in villages without access to water they
have to transport their water containers
to water sources then fill them up and
bring them back to their Villages of
course at a price and it's often
children who are doing this work
skipping school
cecina Clara Sia is one of them she
would prefer to be in school now but she
needs to support her family and the
river is more than 10 kilometers away in
my mind it's difficult for me because
even to carry the water from the river
to the truck is tiring and then from
here to the house
but if we don't have money we don't eat
and drink so we use some of the water
for my family and sell some to neighbors
here to make some money
after two hours of hustling for a lift a
truck finally gives her family and their
40 empty water containers arrived to the
river
Southern Madagascar has always been
poorer and drier than the rest of the
islands the recent drought combined with
Decades of neglect by the central
government has aggravated the situation
we meet the regional Governor he says
their plans to build a road and a
massive water pipe to bring in water
from areas better off but he can't say
when you can expect those problems to be
resolved within uh one year or two years
for the last eight decades nothing has
been done and this is the first
government this is the first regime
which is uh taking care of the whole of
a problem he says residents are also to
blame because for Generations they have
been cutting down the forests in the
area
says she has no energy to think about
who or what is responsible for the
crisis
sometimes the children don't get any
money until the end of the day so we eat
late at night sometimes we don't eat the
whole day we just stay hungry then I
just search for cactus fruits now we
don't have anything to cook so I need to
go and look for cactus fruit so we have
a meal
so once again she Ventures out in the
heat without shoes looking for something
to eat trying to make ends meet finding
food and water is all if I can think of
every day